le ponton est bien là signe que la fête
déduit va bientôt commencer
l'idée vient de nano créé l'instant de
quelques jours un espace culturel au
beau milieu de la loire et la passerelle
tient un rôle majeur
cette passerelle mène à l'inconnu elle
mène au désir almanac l'engagement
d'artistes elle mène à des oeuvres d'art
évidemment à des à des spectacles à des
performances mais ce que je souhaite
surtout c'est qu'elles qu'elles mènent
les citoyens à l'inconnu allons sur sa
terre davanture depuis quelques jours
une vingtaine d'artistes a investi les
lieux
chaque année nano donne le thème et les
créateurs laissent libre cours à leur
imagination dôme istria qui vient de
corse a inventé des personnages qui se
laisse aller à la rêverie
c'est magique et puis un terrain de jeu
extraordinaire du coup ce qu'on a tout
l'espace
le soleil est avec nous aujourd'hui mais
il ya c'était le vent et la pluie mais
c'était bien aussi
et du coup ça nous on s'inspire de cette
force et de cette énergie pour pour être
voilà après disponible et être dans la
création en tous les cas pour pour pour
cet univers magique qu'on nous a proposé
oeuvres éphémères ou pérennes
certaines resteront